so how do we go about this let's uh
let's get this old stuff that's a
mystery solvers
so putty I like to I like to write down
right at the outset what I'm actually
going after because you're gonna go off
to different things and you want to stay
where you're headed in the first place
right so I'm gonna say watch out right
there he and another 10 off my project
up for pot a they left of D H or DT and
for puppy I'm after the base area now a
is a bit of a catch-all name like a
could be the entire area or it could be
just a slant of area that shape which if
you unfold it recover sector but I'm
just going to call B D that's what I'm
after and I want each of those the rate
at which each of there is changing
good morning when the height is
distributors okay so I'm just gonna add
that to both
okay and that's all I need from this
question well that's all the questions
help me okay
so if I went to HR DT and what I know is
DV on detail how do I connect these two
together we've actually been spending a
lot of time doing connecting things like
these together when we've been doing
integration right and we do substitution
how do we connect these things together
yeah I'm gonna need to appeal to chain
rule the reason why is because I've got
DVM DT I've got a selected v2h but the
way that volume and height are related
to each other in a cone is it's the
volume formula is it what is the volume
of the cone it's 1/3 PI R square H which
is actually a really famous not move on
we can prove this actually doing volumes
like just think about the line and then
if you rotate that around and access
you'll get it you'll get a cone so it's
great that we can prove this but now we
just need to use it at the moment so to
get to D H or DT right what I'm gonna
really want D H is I want D H on DV and
DV on duty how do I write that where did
that come from
okay just think about the pieces that I
want and the pieces that I've got to
build this thing okay I want a D H on
the top that means I need the DVS to
cancel this is exactly what was
happening when I was doing integration
by substitution it's like oh I'm
changing the variable here
that's exactly what I'm doing here that
sort of it's just wearing different
clothes okay now when you look at dho DV
that's a bit of your read thing to
calculate B that B key is you
differentiate V with respect to H but I
can do that not to just take the
reciprocal okay so let's do that
this is what I want so in order to get
there to get the piece to go in there
I'm gonna say but I'll actually write it
here
TV on the edge equals okay
so don't be too confused here right
what's going on here
I've actually got a pair of variables
this is a bit of a problem for me right
because I'm only differentiating with
respect to H and it's important you
recognize these are both variables right
it's not like Mar is some number that's
locked in stone I was getting bigger
here's our please H does that make sense
so I'm actually not ready to
differentiate this thing yet I can't
because I need to good one
very good I could have said this from
the beginning I could have actually as
soon as we saw that 45 degrees I could
have said this okay but it wouldn't have
been obvious like I wouldn't have
encountered this problem until I knew
hey way to differentiate this thing it's
not a function of H yes it's a function
of R and edge so I sort of as I go
through the problem realize this is what
I want
therefore I want this therefore I need
to change this as you start to get a
little more familiar with your Oh as
soon as I see this problem I actually
need to make the step in the kitty just
said oh cool this is what kind of
triangle yeah it's an isosceles triangle
so therefore I could say actually R is
equal to H in this particular trial so
in case you miss that step right I've
got a semi vertical angle in here Oh 45
which we dive another angle or 45 over
here because there's a right angle
that's a perpendicular height there you
came with that so lovely that means I
can actually say since R is equal to H
this is really 1/3 PI ah cute but I
don't want it in terms of our dua
I want it in terms of H so instead of
1/3 PI R cubed I'm gonna write
a third PI H cute right okay now a very
different [ __ ] some of the new babies
yeah that's step three just comes out
front it cancels with that one third
then it becomes PI H squared okay so now
that I've got DV on D H what why was I
getting DB on th or in the first place
yeah cuz cuz I actually want D H on TV
so I'm gonna take the reciprocal of this
and then I can that's the V and H so th
on TV is one on H sweat now DL DT that
was the first thing I wrote down that's
just the number why it's constant so I
just multiply this by three so this is
now this is a little bit weird so hold
on a second what was the original
question it was at what rate is the
height changing when the height is two
meters okay now you see they have to
tell you what the height is because
let's ever think about this right what
happens as the height gets larger and
larger and larger as my as my pile of
saying it's bigger and bigger and bigger
what is happening to this whole quantity
it's getting smaller and smaller then
they get to zero it does it will that
make sense cuz it's gonna get bigger and
bigger but it slows down of course it
does because it has to feel a lot more
volume so this this high gets slower and
slower and slower as it grows but now I
can just actually substitute in where H
equals two
yeah okay sir I'm so glad you asked its
traditional just like I'm going to do it
integration right in integral it doesn't
have units but we use it to work out an
area or a MOLLE
right so then I think kind of the nicest
way to say it is just like that a
derivative has no units but what I'm
after is what this derivative represents
is the change in height over time so I
could say therefore the change in height
like what I introduced all this notation
right so I'm gonna put it back into
words the change or the rate of change
in height is and now I'm going to supply
the units this is 3 on 4 pi
what means okay so the units are going
to come from whatever unit I was using
the only units that I have on the board
with me are all from this DB on the team
do you see that so it's in meters and
minutes okay so let's just stop from
them cuz I actually took a bit of a
Secours path through this and I can do
this more directly now I'm a bit more
familiar with these questions
I drew my diagram so I can work out like
the geometry of this thing I took the
result that was given to me in the
question you always get some kind of
constantly this is how much water I'm
pouring you
or this is how much air I'm flowing into
my balloon and then I thought well okay
based on the question are being asked
how can I take all of that and put it
all together into chain okay
channel is the thing you always find
relates your rates together okay now on
the basis of that I wonder if you can
have a go at Part B you're looking at
the area of this base so again you're
gonna have to appeal to some kind of
formula so you can differentiate that
and then relate those rates together why
do you have a shot I'll give you a few
others together